freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen videos ist wieder soweit der
zweite teil vom kochduell heute wirklich
kommt nach unseren regeln ab sofort jede
woche einmal bei freddy und bei mir
nicht anders eggert rally car jeden
verein aber heute gucken wir erst mal
wer von uns beiden ist stamp ey könig
beziehungsweise der pfannkuchen kündigt
jetzt gar nicht festgelegt letzten endes
wird wie immer die jury entscheiden und
ich habe auf jeden fall ein rezept für
euch heute leute das hat es auf jeden
fall in sich aber das wird freddy
probleme bereiten beim letzten mal hat
es ein bisschen schwer zu gewinnen aber
heute wäre ich mir den sieg holen würde
sagen wir rufen einfach mal gemeinsam an
ok also eine stunde ab jetzt bist du
bereit eine stunde ab jetzt ist
eigentlich okay wir haben erstmal auch
im zeitraum von einer stunde gab bei
pancakes kann man da eigentlich
gutschein ich werde mit pancakes machen
warum pancakes müssen dick sein wenn man
das mit mehr macht einfach nur dann
werden sie ihren blick auf hafen ca
aber da kommt die butter richtig spielt
dies schafft sie unglaublich hoch zu
machen dabei unglaublich
dazu gibt's zu glauben mascarpone toffel
wir fangen bezahlbaren hallo es geht los
von meiner seite aus mit pancakes ich
habe mir amerikanische pancakes
ausgesucht max weiß noch nichts davon
aber es wird sexy suite und hoffentlich
fluffig ich probiere nämlich heute auch
was aus gegenwart ist ein weil ich hier
weg vom main pancakes zu 9
und das ist alles ziemlich gefährlich
aber ich glaube das könnte ganz geil
sein schnelldurchlauf anderen zutaten
jahre creme fraiche was capone zitrone
plaudern für das topping ich mache so
eine creme fraiche mascarpone creme
bestreichen wir ein bisschen zucker
häufig zu flambieren bisschen zitronen
feste drauf blaubeeren darüber wird
glaube ich will buttermilch das ist der
charakter von unserem rezept dann
brauchen wir zwei eier butter zucker
backpulver und entweder bei einem zucker
oder vanille extrakt einfach so für eine
band die das ist relativ frei von der
hand alles gemacht ich hab schon butter
geschmolzen
aber wir haben das jetzt durch das geht
nämlich flotte gramm butter
die 250 gramm mehl dazu 50 gramm zucker
ist in motto die besten händen cakes die
ich selbst gegessen habe deshalb erhoffe
ich mir gute chancen dass sich freddy
damit abziehen da leute sie müssen
fertig werden ein ganzes paket
backpulver erstmal drei kaps heißt dass
freud tassen mehl ist ganz normales mehr
wir durch sieben jetzt richtig geil wird
na schön rein gesiebt hier den ganzen
müll noch ein bisschen natron backpulver
damit richtig rein club unfassbar viel
zucker weil nur so gewinnt man das alles
schon mal ein bisschen zusammenrühren so
dass ganze vermengen wird ein bisschen
also die trockenen zutaten ist und dazu
kommen jetzt 500 milliliter buttermilch
unsere geschmolzene butter einfach alles
dazu ein wenig von dem vanille extrakt
das ist aber sehr potent also nicht mal
ein ganzer teelöffel kennen ja auch
schon fast anfangen zu mixen finden noch
zwei eier und mode dorf so und jetzt
können wir auch schon anfang alles zu
vermissen aber da jetzt schon vorsicht
walten lassen wir wollen es nicht über
mixen also lieber ein bisschen zu wenig
wenn man das ganze auspackt dann gehen
diese slums also diese klumpen da drin
sowieso relativ gut weg aber das muss
natürlich trotzdem einmal vermischt sein
so dann haben wir nämlich erste
trockenen zutaten wichtig wir brauchen
jetzt das hier weil wir müssen
wir brauchen vier eier an der zahl das
ding ist halt wir machen die nachher
wieder zusammen aber man braucht das
jetzt in der zubereitung weil das so
wichtig ist machen wir mal die eiweiße
umfüllen in eine große schüssel denn
hier muss es jetzt alles gemischt werden
mit buttermilch brauchen so fast 500 500
liter 500 milliliter
das wird das hier alles mal ein bisschen
miteinander vermischen aufgestellt ich
sag's dir sogar klassischer fall von
circa eine so
dann jetzt gleich das hier sollte jetzt
dass david halt nicht nicht zu warm sein
nicht zu kalt sein damit machst du
nämlich gleich hier raus wollen wir auch
nicht dass hier noch mal schön schön
einrühren die sachen haben wir jetzt zu
einem gemacht das führen wir jetzt
zusammen dann haben wir nämlich die
grundzutaten von unseren flüssigen dann
kommen dann nämlich unsere trockenen
zutaten rein und dann wird es im prinzip
nur noch vermischt und dann nehmen wir
jetzt kein rühren
mehr sondern wir nehmen mit ihren denkt
so ein spachtel und spachteln das dann
darunter ihr sehen könnt das ganze sei
es jetzt ein bisschen dadurch dass wir
es nicht krass gemixt haben ist es gut
ist ein bisschen stehen zu lassen
dadurch wird das meer mit flüssigkeit
versorgt haben schönen homogenen teig
der wird extra dick jetzt natürlich dass
wir ihn so wenig gemischt haben wir
machen das ganze mit butter aus hier
drüben habe ich schon mal zum warmhalten
den backofen an auf niedrigster stufe 50
grad wichtig auch die größe von pentax
ich finde petrics dürfen nicht die sich
sein dann sind die irgendwie nicht sogar
müssen klein relativ klein sein
man muss die staffeln können so ihr
versteht hoffentlich was ich meine
wir geben ordentlich futter reinlassen
dir erstmal schmelzen machen hier vorne
aber in der experimentier küche weiter
mit meiner mascarpone empfehle ich eine
gute ecke mascarpone ein wenig creme
fraiche dann brauchen wir eine ecke
zitrone aber nur für den test gehen wir
ein bisschen rein und dann das gleiche
umstellt haben um den kreis zu schließen
ein tröpfchen vanille extrakt ein klein
wenig zucker sind alles nicht viel das
sind einfach nur noten mit denen ich
gearbeitet dann ruhig das ganze hier ein
weit so ein bisschen ein mal gucken ob
das funktioniert so wie ich im kopf habe
und das ganze jetzt so ein bisschen
hier ist jetzt probieren obwohl es auch
erst mit einer küchenmaschine machen
aber es muss wohl alles mit hand gemacht
werden dort wohl auch diese diese
flugplatz haben mit dem diese mail
bubbles und dann ganz kurz im
kühlschrank und dann wird schon gebracht
das stück wenn ja gut so die bahn ist
leer
wir backen die letzten pancake ich meine
sie nicht perfekt runden ist okay es ist
hier drin ist unser bisheriges deck und
der geschmack dreht ist auf jeden fall
man kann das ganz natürlich auch mit so
einer form backen aber quatsch
[Musik]
hallo freunde trainings hinter der
kamera
hier sind unsere beiden teller und der
vielleicht schon im juli statt zu sehen
das ist das bessere respekt auf jeden
fall
wir bieten jetzt nach nach unseren drei
tester ein und dann bewerten jetzt erst
mal das aussehen
hallo könig hier begrüßen zu dürfen ja
ich bin ich freue mich bin sehr gespannt
was ihr hier fabriziert und packt aus
also zu meiner rechten zu eurer linken
okay es sieht aus als wäre es ziemlich
basic ahornsirup oder irgend etwas
ähnliches blaubeeren sehr schick auf der
anderen seite ok also rein machen look
entscheide ich mich für die pancakes zu
meiner linken oder linke hier halt so
ist so ich vorher mal rauslassen
ich sag die wahrheit da sind die
pfannkuchen bisschen besser uns nicht
fehlt ist das ist es deshalb dass das
projekt endlich der wichtigen part der
geschmack wird in recke aus und helfen
reinigen die macht muss natürlich von
allem etwas mitnehmen
die sind schon sehr gut sehr leicht
dafür dass es eigentlich pancakes sind
wir super frisch daneben wie eine
zitrone gelohnt die blaubeere macht auch
noch mal unter sierung wirklich richtig
gut hier gehe ich davon aus dass es
deutlich schwerer wir zu kommen aber das
heißt ja nicht unbedingt etwas
schlechtes
er ist noch was drin erst mal
grundsätzlich bevor ich mich entscheide
beide unfassbar gut wirklich toll im ort
gewinnt für mich geschmacks mäßig diese
sei schwer war es für mich beim ok da
schon mal dieses geld war schließlich
echt schwierig also ich muss sagen wir
sehen finde ich den teig leider montiert
will ich die schublade du bist ja
natürlich
hallo contest ich musste was machen sie
hat ein vergleich der straße ist wenn
pfand fällig sind ja hier sieht man
richtig gut wenn ich die gabel run druck
dass vetter aus fließt das ist vorn und
jetzt durch zu verlieren werde er aber
nicht geschmeckt europa nicht total auf
zitronen april wirklich kommt der aktion
aber wenn ich finde
obwohl die so fertig sind sind die ein
bisschen leichter als das muss ganz
ehrlich sagen für mich persönlich nur
mein geschmack würden wir das hier
besser schmecken weil die top teams um
dieses jetzt gerade geht bei den
pfannkuchen haben bei den rufen nach
seiner selbst schmeckt der deutsche mit
ein bisschen gala als die ja und deshalb
würde ich mich tatsächlich bestimmt wird
einfach freude das war unser erstes
richtiges gut battle wirklich ich hatte
richtig angst als du deinem euro gemacht
das hat und an manchen tagen pervers aus
sollte es auch sein wird auch zwei von
drei leute natürlich gewinnen können in
punkto aussehen
ich hatte zwei freien schmeckt das heißt
irgendwie ist es unentschieden
ich mache ja im prinzip doch dass wir
immer schon so gemacht haben deswegen
bei mir immer gut dass sich youtube bin
weil ich scheiße dass sie keine
ressourcen und bin ich zufrieden mit
muss ich sage also dass da gehen wir bei
gut raus ja ein auge ist immer wird das
ist halt was wo wir bei uns auch immer
mehr mühe geben wenn wir
jetzt machen deswegen gold mit
einbeziehen fall sehr viel spaß man am
nächsten donnerstag könnte sein hat sehr
viel spaß macht auch sein dass crytek
oder mittwoch ist weil ich habe nur
jeden zweiten tag upload und nicht immer
jeden donnerstag aber er ist